Recently, I had a surprise
while returning home
from a trip changing planes.
I was squeezing out of
an economy class seat,
grabbing my bag, and running
through a crowded quarter.
Wasn't a lot of fun.
But then I get to the gate
of my final flight home,
and I was greeted
with a notice that I'd
been upgraded to business class
because of my frequent flyer
status in the airline.
I felt like I'd won the lottery.
These kind of upgrades
are all around us.
Hotels reward loyal customers
for an extra night's stay.
Coffee shops can give
you 10th drink free
or maybe give you a
discount if you come back
later that afternoon.
And big game
companies are already
starting to follow suit
and apply that to games.
Now, providing that kind
of personalized touch
is within easy reach
of all game developers.
Hi.
I'm Noah Falstein, a
developer advocate for games,
and I'm here to tell you
about the new Player Stats
API that's now part of
Google Play Games Services.
Making successful
games can be tough,
but knowing a few key statistics
about each of your players
makes it easier for you to
identify individual gamer
styles, patterns,
preferences, and then
you can customize your
responses to match
each of those individuals.
For free-to-play games,
it's really helpful
to identify your big
spenders and encourage them
with some special game
power-ups or maybe a bonus match
to their spending habits.
When you spot a player who's
been gone for a long time
and is coming back
after a long absence,
you can make their reentry a
little bit easier by dropping
difficulty a notch, or maybe
you can turn tutorial options
back on.
Finding your most
loyal veteran players
lets you offer them easy
options to tell their friends
about your game without spamming
the new players who may still
be on a learning curve.
And what's more,
the Player Stats API
is free and easy to incorporate.
Making a quality
statistical package
can really be time
consuming, and frankly,
a pain to create
it, to maintain it.
So why not use ours instead?
Now, big companies who
are managing many games
will have different needs than
individuals or small startups,
and the API takes
that into account.
A large company with
their own infrastructure
can call the stats
server to server,
handling communications with
the game clients on their own.
A smaller company, though,
can call the API directly
from their game
client, and then later,
if their needs
grow to justify it,
they can switch over to
a server-to-server model.
So how do you incorporate
the Player Stats API
into your game?
Well, first, you create
a GoogleApiClient client
object and configure it to
use the Games API and SCOPE.
Then you use code like
this to retrieve statistics
on a player.
You can pick and choose which
stats are relevant to you,
and then you can make a
tailored response using those.
So you can add your
own code to customize
a gamer's experience
for your specific needs
and make them feel valued.
So, for example, you
might give a novice player
some extra help,
or a veteran player
a power up as an incentive
to come back and use it
in their next session.
It may not be as satisfying as
a business class flight upgrade,
but even free tokens
at the right time
can make someone's day.
Here's a link to some
additional documentation
if you want more
detail or suggestions
on how to use the API.
Those steps will get you started
on using the Player Stats
API so you can refine your
game and target those responses
to players individually,
make them happier,
and make your games
more profitable.
So have fun, and let
us know in comments
if you have any new
ways that you've
thought of using the stats
to make your games better.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]